[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show
i'm your host paul aka the guy who hates
himself more than he who remains
and with loki season one now over i
thought we'd look into the time stream
to see what could be coming down the
line
the disney plus marvel show is the first
of its kind to get a second season
and throughout this video we'll be going
over everything we know about it so far
as well as some of the things that the
new marvel studios assembled special
told us about the series full spoilers
for the ending of the season too so
i suggest you get pruned before you get
ruined if you haven't had a chance to
check it out
it is your glorious purpose to like the
video and don't forget to subscribe as
we still have a lot more marvel videos
coming down the line
without the way thank you for clicking
this now let's get into everything we
know about loki season two
okay so way before season two was
announced in the post-credits scene of
episode six
producer nate moore told indiewire that
loki was planned to be a multiple season
orc
and potentially we could be getting far
beyond season two
clark gregg who you will know for
playing agent coulson let it slip to
variety that tom hiddleston was working
on far more than the six episodes we saw
in season one
and he said the actor was going to be
doing in between 10 and 12.
his full quote was i'd be lying if i
didn't say boy
that would really be interesting to
start the experiment over
doing 10 episodes or 12 episodes the way
that tom hiddleston told me he was doing
on loki
with that kind of budget and that
marvel's cinematic production team
now whether this is him just getting the
episode amount wrong or just 10 to 12
episodes for season 2
we don't know however according to
production weekly
filming for season 2 will start in
january 2022
so potentially tom could be filming
another 6 or 12 more
and this will likely be dropping at the
end of 2022
or the start of 2023 disney have a super
fast turnaround on these series and so
far they've managed to wrap everything
up in less than a year
now strangely it was reported by the
hollywood reporter
that tom hiddleston's loki was expected
to appear in the upcoming film
doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness this is actually due to release
in march 2022
which would mean that we would see the
character appear in that before
returning for the second season
potentially strange might save him from
the situation we found him in at the end
of episode 6
and loki could explain exactly why the
multiverse is falling apart
it must be said though that disney
haven't confirmed this at all however
marvel maniacs did notice that
hiddleston had his infamous lucky
hairstyle during january of this year
which is when the doctor strange sequel
was filming so it is possible that he
appears during this movie
before returning to the tva for season
2. now unfortunately it still hasn't
been cleared up exactly what happened at
the end of season 1.
there is two trains of thought though at
the moment but i don't think anyone can
say for definite
exactly what the ending meant now the
first one is the one that i tend to side
with and that is that loki traveled into
an alternate timeline
in which a version of nathaniel richards
had risen up and taken over the tba
this is why mobius didn't know who he
was and why the timekeepers also didn't
exist now this is possible because
before selfie kicked loki through the
tempat doorway the timeline fractured
off into a branch and therefore it is
possible that he traveled to an
alternate universe
now the other possibility i've seen
people say is that loki has returned to
the original tva
but everyone has had their memories
wiped this would explain why mobius
doesn't know who he is
and as we know the tva aren't opposed to
wiping people's memories
just don't make him forget about the jet
ski please please we need that jetski
now let me know below exactly what you
think is the right one however i tend to
lean more towards the first one
i think mobius just doesn't remember
because he's never met the guy before
now as for the cast of season 2 disney
haven't officially announced to is
returning
but we can expect to see loki sylvie
mobius ravona and slayer
and of course hunter b15 it is likely
that jonathan mages will be returning
too
and we know that he's also due to show
up in ant-man quantum mania
the film will be releasing worldwide in
february 2023
and this does line up a lot with the
production schedule of loki as well
so potentially we could be getting lucky
at the end of 2022
and from there it might play out for six
weeks which would allow it to finish up
before we head into that future film
in an interview with comicbookmovie.com
jonathan mages teased that what could be
coming
and he said that kang will very much be
in opposition to he who remains
now this not only goes into the idea of
kang going head to head with himself
in order to create a multiversal war but
also the character betrayal
mages has made it very clear that the
characterization he brings to kang
will be completely different to how he
played he who remains
i absolutely love the ambiguity that's
gonna be coming with
all the different variants when it comes
to kang and the versions that we meet
you really don't know if he's gonna be a
good one or a bad one
and it just creates so many
possibilities we could even end up with
an avengers forever situation in which
kang seemingly was on the side of the
avengers but he betrayed them and yet
anything is possible with the character
it's like this channel you might get
good video
you might get a bad one you don't know
and that's the gamble people
take now i love that kang is also so
scary that even kang is scared of kang
and it just leads to a world of
possibilities coming down the line
now unfortunately the season 1 director
kate herron
will not be returning to lead the second
season i've seen a lot of people with
the
with an anti-woke agenda saying that
this is because she was fired or that
the show was a flop
but there's no real evidence for that
and looking at what's been said
she stepped down because she had other
commitments in an interview with l
magazine herron said that salvi will be
getting an even bigger role
and when discussing the next chapter in
the character's arc she teased that it
would be about self-healing
she said that we will pick up with her
still in the citadel and after ripping
the time stream apart
she will dig deep into herself in order
to tackle why she betrayed loki
and the cost of this action so lots of
things to look forward to coming down
the line
and as for season one we did learn a lot
in the marvel studios assembled special
now the first big thing they revealed
was that selfie
was indeed based upon sylvie lushton
throughout our videos we theorized that
she was an amalgamation of the character
from the comics
that was combined with a loki variant
this turned out to be true and in case
you don't know
sylvia is actually the second version of
the marvel universe enchantress
and loki gave her her powers in order to
toy with her
selfie was actually given false memories
and convinced that she was as guardian
in a sick and twisted game by lucky so
who knows they might even say that for a
twist on the line with the character in
other seasons
personally i'm at the point now where i
think she will just stay a variant
and therefore it'll keep in with the
show's theme of learning to love
yourself
now other things we found out were that
he who remains was so scared of himself
that he actually built the fortress of
the citadel in order to protect himself
from his other variants though he was
indeed the last version of nathaniel
richards
if the tva were unable to stop a branch
from traveling past the red
line a kang variant would rise up and
thus he needed to protect himself with
both the fortress and
also alaia interestingly the citadel 2
featured in avengers forever
and we learned that it was part of a
mortise's castle in the comics there's a
big amortis versus kang war throughout
the timeline
and this location could be hinting
towards that in the upcoming seasons
mages said that he based the character
on people like the wizard of oz
willy wonka and several great and
powerful people that turned into
tricksters over time he also went into
the costume design of he who remains
and said the following one of the great
things i got to experience with our
costume designer
is that every piece we decided on was
from a different place
the cave i had on was from the victorian
era the shoes were from genghis khan
the pants from mongolia etc etc
you just mix and match it together and
it informs the character
lastly they said that kang is bent on
destruction and this is why the ending
is still
something that gives me goosebumps we
know that when loki arrived to the tva
that hunter b15 thought kang was
allowing these branches to just sleep
out
and it is possible that he wants to
create the multiversal wall
which might be how the show culminates
before we head into what i think will be
secret wars
i do think that he who remains version
will be back too and as he said
allowing kang to rise up will lead to
his reincarnation
this means that if the war gets out of
hand it's inevitable that he too will
rise
up and streamline the timeline once more
leading to the events to loop around
again
it's really fascinating stuff and uh
just me explaining it for myself is
imagine if you're drunk yeah you send
loads of drunk texts
the next morning you wake up you send
the apology one saying look it wasn't me
yet
it was my variant it was kang it's
something i'm sure we can all relate to
in life and yeah that's that's basically
the multiversal wall
playing out before our very eyes it's
all really fascinating stuff
and hopefully this video has filled you
in on everything we know so far about
the upcoming second season
as well as more things about how much of
an idiot i am
now obviously i'd love to hear your
thoughts on the show and what you wanna
see in season two
comment below and let me know and just
to let you know we're running a
competition right now and giving away
three mcu box sets on the 30th of july
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe with notifications on
and drop a comment below with your
thoughts on season two we picked the
comments at random at the end of the
month and the winners of the last one
are on screen right now
say that's you then message me on
twitter at heavyspoilers if you want
something else to watch then make sure
you check out our breakdown of all the
easter eggs in space jam
it was absolutely soul destroying i'm
not gonna lie to you
one of the most difficult videos i've
ever made and it underperformed
so yeah please go over there and give me
some likes without the way
thank you for clicking this i've been
paul i'll see you next time
take care peace